zone Europe sur sensation
[Musique]
et bienvenue dans zone Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 une émission
enregistrée en Espagne l'Espagne est
membre de l'Union européenne depuis le
1er janvier 1986 elle est aussi membre
de la zone euro depuis le 1er janvier
1999 et pour ce numéro spécial nous
sommes à Madrid deuxième plus grande
ville de l'Union européenne derrière
Berlin la capitale espagnole est connue
pour ses nombreux musées un club de foot
prestigieux le Real le farniente et
enfin ses éventails
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la France est le premier partenaire
commercial de l'Espagne j'ai rendez-vous
avec Bertrand Barthélemy le directeur de
la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
franco-espagnol une institution à
laquelle plus de 600 entreprises
adhèrent
zone Europe
bonjour Bertrand Barthélemy
cette institution qui est la CCI
France-Espagne existe depuis la fin du
19e siècle quelles sont ses missions et
ses principaux objectifs alors la
chambre franco-espagnol a été créée en
1894 à l'origine c'était une initiative
qui a été lancée par des entrepreneurs
français qui étaient présents en Espagne
la mission clairement a évolué sur la
période donc maintenant à l'heure
actuelle nous sommes une association qui
regroupe un peu plus de 550 sociétés
adhérentes et nous avons une double
finalité d'une part nous sommes un club
d'affaires c'est-à-dire que nous animons
cette communauté d'affaires et par
ailleurs nous sommes également
qu'en est-il des relations économiques
entre la France et l'Espagne alors les
relations économiques entre la France et
l'Espagne sont très intenses ou très
longtemps c'est je pense la chance qu'à
une structure comme la nôtre d'être dans
un pays où il y a finalement une très
forte la proximité de la France et donc
une forte richesse des échanges
la deuxième élément qu'il faudrait
considérer quand on veut aborder le
marché espagnol c'est que la proximité
de la France peut faire croire que c'est
un marché de proximité qui est simple
avec des similitudes culturelles alors
qu'en fait il y a une dimension
interculturelle de la négociation qui ne
font pas négliger et qui peut qui peut
faire que des entreprises commettent des
impairs si elles ne connaissent pas
réellement la culture de l'autre pays
d'où l'intérêt de se faire accompagner
par des interlocuteurs qui sont plus que
je dirais bilingue vie culturel alors
nous sommes à Madrid aujourd'hui mais
vous avez également d'autres délégations
territoriales partout dans le pays
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres communautés
autonomes espagnoles qui peuvent être
intéressantes du point de vue économique
pour les entreprises françaises oui
alors à l'occasion de notre 120e
anniversaire la Chambre a amené une
réflexion sur son développement
territorial nous avions une délégation
historique à Valence puisque la
communauté Valenciennes est une des
régions à fort potentiel en Espagne et
suite à la réflexion qui était menée aux
opportunités que nous avons identifiées
nous sommes implantés dans les régions
où là où nous voyons le plus fort
potentiel nous sommes par exemple en
Andalousie avec deux délégations une
amalaga et une assez vie nous sommes
également au Pays Basque avec une
délégation à Bilbao en Aragon avec une
délégation à Saragosse en castillole
avec une délégation riadolides et puis
ensuite nous sommes dans les îles aux
Baléares à Palma et au Canaries à
Tenerife et ce sont les communautés où
nous avons identifié le plus fort
potentiel enfin pour finir on est dans
un contexte un peu compliqué post covid
est-ce que justement c'est un bon moment
pour pour se lancer pour entreprendre en
Espagne ou au contraire il faut attendre
encore un petit peu
alors j'aurais tendance à dire que pour
toute entreprise qui a un projet sérieux
qu'elle est bien préparé c'est un bon
moment pour entreprendre je veux dire
qu'au niveau de nos activités c'est vrai
que nous avons souffert de la pandémie
puisque nous nous vendons du réseau du
contact et puis également donc des mises
en rapport d'entreprises de pays avec la
pandémie tout cela c'est freiné très
fortement mais une activité que nous
avons qui s'est maintenue et qui a
progressé était celle justement d'aide à
l'implantation de domiciliation et de
gestion administrative et on se rend
compte que maintenant on a beaucoup de
demandes d'entreprise qui veulent
s'implanter ici donc ça peut être soit
des filiales soit des Français qui
viennent en Espagne et qui montent un
établissement permanent ou qui montre
une structure propre qu'on peut appeler
un établissement français à l'étranger
donc il y a ensuite le télétravail qui a
fait aussi que beaucoup de Français
viennent travailler depuis l'Espagne et
ça puisse leur donner une idée de créer
un projet ici je voudrais les mettre en
garde aussi sur le fait que être nomade
digital c'est très bien mais que ça peut
avoir un impact fiscal qu'il ne faut pas
négliger et on incite les entreprises
qui sont en situation à regarder de près
la législation merci beaucoup Bertrand
Barthélémy d'avoir été avec nous j'ai
appris un plaisir je rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur de la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie franco-espagnol
ici à Madrid parmi les musées madrilène
les plus célèbres on retrouve le musée
de la Reina Sofia ou encore le musée du
Prado mais aujourd'hui dans zone Europe
nous allons vous faire découvrir la Casa
nsendida nous avons tout de suite
rendez-vous avec Lucia kassani la
directrice hola Lucia Cassani
première question pourquoi ce lieu
s'appelle la maison allumée quelle est
la signification
ça s'appelle la maison allumée car c'est
le nom d'un poème d'un poète espagnol
des années 50 qui s'appelle Luis rozalez
en plus c'est l'idée très belle d'un
espace vivant rempli de gens une maison
allumée c'est un musée dans lequel des
gens vivent et c'est un peu l'idée de ce
lieu un espace dans lequel il se passe
toujours quelque chose et remplit
d'énergie
quelles sont les différentes missions de
la Casa snvida à quoi sert-elle
la Fondation
est un centre culturel et social de la
Fondation montée Madrid nous sommes
principalement concentrés sur la culture
contemporaine pour comprendre le présent
et répondre un peu aux différentes
problématiques qui se produisent de nos
jours à travers quatre Aires d'action
que sont la culture l'environnement la
solidarité
et à partir de ces quatre disons mission
comme tu as dit nous essayons de
proposer des activités nous avons aussi
ce que nous appelons un centre de
ressources nous sommes un centre
d'éducation non formelle
plymelo d'abord je voudrais parler des
expositions en ce moment il y a une
exposition qui s'appelle créature
vulnérable c'est une réflexion sur la
récente pandémie quel est le message de
cette exposition quoi c'est le médecin
expositions
en réalité l'exposition créatures
vulnérable est née d'une enquête des
commissaires Ivan Lopez Mounira et
Andrea Bagnato qui a débuté en 2018 il
tente d'analyser les conséquences des
virus et des pandémies et plus
généralement l'histoire ils n'ont pas
attendu qu'arrive le covid-19 et de fait
c'est une exposition qui s'est vu
complètement rattrapée par cette
nouvelle pandémie mais ce n'est pas
spécifiquement sur le covid elle veut
nous faire réfléchir comment les virus
nous affectent tant nous les humains
comme les non humains et nous devons
commencer à pouvoir vivre avec eux de la
meilleure manière possible d'une autre
manière ils invitent aussi à retrouver
le contact cette dernière pandémie le
choc que nous avons eu nous a aussi
isolé séparé et cette exposition est une
manière de retrouver l'idée d'être à
nouveau ensemble alors on a mal
exposition intéressante elle s'appelle
inédit 2022 cette année c'est la
vingtième édition d'inédit c'est quoi le
concepto
avec la Fondation
espagnol
moins de 35 ans le concours pour que
présente leurs projets
et nous la présentons à la maison animée
quels sont les deux projets gagnants
cette année cette année
les deux projets gagnants cette année
sont deux projets féminins Nuria Gomez
Gabriel qui a présenté un projet qui
s'appelle les méchants qui à travers
différentes œuvres d'artistes
contemporains nous fait réfléchir sur
l'idée du mal et comme certaines fois
nous voyons l'idée du mal comme quelque
chose qui est en dehors de nous on
comprend que non c'est quelque chose que
nous partageons tous et la deuxième
exposition s'appelle devenir une île de
Enya pomer claquelle c'est une réflexion
sur l'idée d'îles et d'archipel c'est
aussi l'idée d'un appel à être de
nouveau ensemble à comprendre les
différentes relations et différentes
questions qui peuvent se poser
merci beaucoup
je rappelle que vous êtes la directrice
du musée la casa nsendida
[Musique]
l'Espagne c'est la première destination
Erasmus pour les étudiants français ils
étaient en 2021
4267 avenue étudier ici et découvrir une
nouvelle culture je vais tout de suite
rendez-vous avec alphonseau rentyl le
directeur du service pour
l'internationalisation de l'éducation
bonjour alphon rentil bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous dans zone
Europe bonjour c'est un plaisir de avoir
avec vous aujourd'hui
orthododel mundo tout le monde connaît
le programme Erasmus mais c'est quoi
Erasmus plus et ses priorités priori
d'Hadès et l'amour plus est un programme
qui s'adresse à tout le secteurs
éducatifs de l'éducation scolaire à
l'éducation supérieure mais aussi à
l'éducation pour les adultes et les
formations professionnelles et ce n'est
pas seulement un programme de mobilité
étudiante mais aussi de professeurs et
de professionnels il va plus loin le
plus va plus loin que la mobilité on
souhaite améliorer les centres éducatifs
et tous les bénéficiaires qui
participent au programme les priorités
pour la période 2021 2027 sont la
digitalisation la durabilité ou
l'environnement la participation et la
vie démocratique et l'inclusion
années en 2022 nous célébrons les 35 ans
du programme Erasmus et c'est l'année
aussi de la jeunesse dans l'Union
européenne tout cela a-t-il un impact
sur les travaux du CP sauvez l'os traba
rose
delpieds spécifiques pour célébrer ce
35e anniversaire avec chacun des
secteurs et nous collaborons avec
l'agence de la jeunesse en Espagne elle
s'appelle une trouvée pour d'autres
actions en rapport avec l'Année de la
jeunesse
quels sont les derniers chiffres de
participation des étudiants de
l'éducation supérieure espagnole et quel
est le pays qui choisissent le plus en
Europe et Europa leader les chiffres les
plus actualisés que nous avons date de
2019 c'est plus de
40900 étudiants espagnols qui sont allés
dans d'autres pays européens du
programme
Erasmus plus la première destination et
l'Italie après le Royaume-Uni et la
France est en troisième position suivi
de l'Allemagne et de la Pologne
contrario dans le sens inverse l'Espagne
est la première destination Erasmus pour
les étudiants français comment expliquer
vous ce succès
successo
l'Espagne la première destination
Erasmus en général dans le secteur de
l'éducation supérieure la majorité des
pays européens choisissent l'Espagne pas
seulement les Français le succès des
universités espagnoles se doit au fait
qu'elles sont bien situées dans les
classements pour ce qui est de la
connaissance nous sommes un pays leader
dans le secteur de la recherche nous
avons une grande qualité de vie nos
universités et sont situés dans les
centres-villes nous avons aussi des
campus aux abords des villes pour des
raisons de confort en conclusion nous
avons une offre aussi bien culturelle
gastronomique de qualité de vie et
surtout des universités de qualité ce
qui fait que nous sommes chaque fois
plus attractifs
à un jeune espagnol quand il revient en
Espagne après sa mobilité il a une
meilleure employabilité
les gens qui participent au programme
Erasmus plus en général améliore leurs
compétences pour trouver un travail plus
de 90% de ceux qui ont vécu une mobilité
à ce muscle trouve un emploi dans
l'année qui suit la fin de leurs études
et 80% de ceux qui ont participé au
programme nous disent via l'enquête qui
a réalisé la Commission européenne
qu'ils ont amélioré leur capacité pour
parler comme pour comprendre les autres
parler d'autres langues ils peuvent donc
trouver du travail plus facilement
comment
facilement merci beaucoup
[Musique]
l'Espagne reçoit environ 48 000
étudiants en Erasmus chaque année dont
9,8% de français rencontre avec certains
d'entre eux alors je m'appelle Audrey
gravine Mercier j'ai 20 ans alors je
m'appelle Thaïs j'ai 20 ans et je suis
en troisième année de l'Anglet
littérature et civilisations espagnoles
et je fais ma troisième année en est
responsable
pourquoi avoir fait une mobilité la
principale motivation c'était de
perfectionner mon espagnol de voyager
aussi de découvrir j'ai toujours été
attiré par par les Spies tout ce qu'on
pouvait faire ici et j'ai découvert
aussi que du coup je pouvais apprendre
bien plus que ça une nouvelle culture un
nouveau mode de vie enfin beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres choses plus tard je
veux faire professeur d'espagnol donc
faire un eresmus en Espagne c'était
quelque chose de un peu obligatoire pour
moi parce que je voulais m'améliorer
etc et la vie madrilène c'est la vie
quand on pense à la vie espagnole c'est
ça c'est la capitale etc donc en quoi
cette expérience va-t-elle vous servir
selon moi ça c'est un plus dans
l'enrichissement qu'on peut faire au
niveau du travail j'ai appris des
nouvelles méthodes de travail avec des
oui des nouvelles personnes des nouveaux
professeurs mais qui sont tout autre que
ce qu'on peut apprendre en France et
aussi d'un point de vue donc
professionnel mais aussi personnel ou on
a enfin personnellement j'ai énormément
grandi et évolué c'est une autre
autonomie qu'on acquiert donc beaucoup
de choses sur ces deux plans là la vie à
Madrid va me servir pour connaître
culturellement l'Espagne vraiment et pas
rester dans dans des a priori ou des
dire qu'on m'a fait plutôt dans ma vie
etc
quel est votre quotidien une journée
type à Madrid en tant que Erasmus elle
est elles peuvent être assez chargées
mais parce que nous on les remplit bien
on commence les cours plus ou moins ça
on fait nos propres emploi du temps donc
ça varie personnellement je commençais
plutôt vers 10h et je finissais vers 21h
mais j'avais des jours après de libre
dans la semaine
euh donc on va en cours le midi on se
retrouve avec nos amis on va à la
cafétéria on a des heures de pause on
pose on bosse ensemble et puis le soir
souvent on avait des soirées de libre on
pouvait se rejoindre faire plus des
activités culturelles ou même sortir
entre nous et aller boire un verre on se
lève on va à l'université
en général on retrouve ses amis moi je
retrouve une amie tous les matins on
prend le métro ensemble on va en cours
ensemble et le soir on rentre on envoie
des messages dans des groupes pour
savoir qui veut aller sortir prendre un
verre aller faire un pique-nique etc et
on rencontre du monde que ce soit
français espagnol et toutes les
nationalités
que dire aux jeunes pour les convaincre
de faire une mobilité du tout vraiment
Nancy a bien une expérience à faire
c'est de partir moi je suis partie un an
j'ai plus du tout envie de repartir de
quitter Madrid
oui non mais vraiment pas hésiter et
foncez parce que c'est une expérience
vraiment incroyable on rencontre des
gens incroyables et qui mine de rien je
pense nous nous change un peu pour tout
le reste après de notre vie s'ils ont la
possibilité qu'ils y aille qu'ils aient
pas peur de
oui non s'ils doivent aller en Erasmus
il faut pas qu'ils aient peur s'ils en
ont la possibilité que ce soit pour la
langue que ce soit pour
je sais pas n'importe quelle peur qu'ils
ont peur d'être autonome non il faut y
aller faut foncer et c'est une
expérience inoubliable et ils vont ils
vont adorer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment elle est conne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Madrid est une ville incontournable en
Europe la capitale espagnole regorge de
lieux culturels Alice et Émilie sont
deux expatriés françaises qui ont lancé
un blog vive Madrid nous avons
rendez-vous avec elle
vive Madrid c'est donc un bloc qui
existe maintenant depuis plus de deux
ans qu'est-ce qui vous a donné envie à
toutes les deux de vous lancer dans ce
projet
alors on est arrivé toutes les deux à
peu près en même temps il y a quatre ans
on s'est rencontré rapidement après
notre arrivée et on avait un peu la même
problématique c'est qu'on était en
reconversion en fait on avait quitté nos
emplois à Paris pour suivi de conjoint
donc mobilité professionnelle à Madrid
en famille on est venu en famille tous
les deux on s'est rencontrés et Émilie
avait déjà un projet de site internet et
on s'est dit que on allait allier nos
forces pour créer voilà un projet un peu
plus grand un peu plus voilà ambitieux
pour voilà pour pour faire partager aux
expatriés et aux touristes qui viennent
à Madrid
toute notre aventure en fait après il y
avait aussi
une problématique on a rencontré quand
on est arrivé c'est que on avait trouvé
assez peu d'informations sur
l'installation faire tous ses papiers
administratifs etc parce que nous on
n'est pas arrivé dans le cas d'une
expatriation classique professionnelle
donc on a dû tout faire par nous-mêmes
et c'était assez compliqué de trouver
des informations
mises à jour donc on s'était dit que bah
déjà partagé notre propre expérience
pour et peut-être aider d'autres
Français qui allaient venir s'installer
ici alors ça fait 4 ans maintenant que
vous vivez à Madrid vous nous l'avez dit
quels sont les principales différences
qu'il peut y avoir entre la vie ici à
Madrid et la vie en France
alors en tant que famille je pense que
Emile t'auras un peu la même remarque
en tant que famille avec des jeunes
enfants c'est vrai que on a trouvé on
trouve que la vie elle est beaucoup plus
facile que c'est voilà l'ambiance est
plus relax en fait quand on est avec des
jeunes enfants quand on se balade dans
la rue dans les quand on va au resto
quand on va dans les musées c'est vrai
que ça on a plus le noter voilà que les
Espagnols et voilà étaient plus patients
étaient plus
passion avec les enfants avec voilà plus
relax ça on a pu le noter après c'est
pas très loin donc c'est assez similaire
mais le rythme de vie bien sûr les
horaires le riz aussi les horaires donc
ça c'est vraiment typique de l'Espagne
c'est que voilà l'heure du déjeuner
beaucoup plus tard lors du des repas
sont décalés et ça il faut s'y faire et
on s'y fait petit à petit et encore on a
encore nos petites habitudes françaises
de temps en temps après si tu vois oui
ben c'est tu as dit le principal ici il
y a quand même une bienveillance
générale qui qui rend la vie quotidienne
très très agréable en fait c'est la vie
est douce et plutôt
bienveillante quoi de manière générale
et avec des familles et aussi enfin sans
être en famille aussi alors vivre Madrid
c'est le nom de votre blog je le
rappelle vous proposez une série de bons
plans pour les touristes français les
expatriés comment est-ce que vous faites
pour trouver dénicher tous ces tous ces
bons plans comment est-ce que vous vous
y prenez
alors on va quand on se balade c'est
vrai qu'on on se dit on va aller dans
telle exposition voir tel musée donc en
général on se balade autour dans Madrid
et dans ce cas là on peut trouver par
hasard des bonnes adresses de restaurant
ou pour sortir ou des parcs et après
sinon si on peut se voilà pour on peut
aussi faire des recherches un petit peu
en amont pour savoir par exemple nous
arrivent souvent de travailler dans des
cafés ou voilà on peut travailler et du
coup on essaye de du coup de chercher un
petit peu
en amont des bonnes adresses qu'on l'air
sympa on les teste et puis si c'est bien
on en parle et on partage les adresses
ouais c'est ça c'est un peu de veille et
enfin peu de recherche de veille après
on teste des fois c'est aussi un peu de
bouche à oreille avec des amis espagnols
ou français qui partagent aussi des fois
des lieux
donc c'est un petit peu de tout en fait
et après on partage que ce qu'on aime ce
qu'on a aimé en fait tout ce qu'on
trouve utile en tout cas pour nos
lecteurs à Madrid il y a une grande
communauté française communauté
d'expatriés
quels seraient les quartiers que vous
conseillerez pour de futurs
expatriés justement ou certains qui
hésiteraient à venir s'installer dans la
capitale espagnole
[Musique]
jouer sur internet et sur Instagram
il relève
que signifie
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de manger ici à Madrid
alors quand on pense à la cuisine
espagnole on pense évidemment à la
paella ou tapas au Ramon ou encore à la
tortilla nous avons tout de suite
rendez-vous avec lui le chef du
restaurant La Barre routière il va nous
présenter une recette
oui bien gracias merci d'être avec nous
tuer le chef du restaurant La barroutia
à Madrid quel est l'esprit de ce lieu
les Spirito
ce lieu cette année fête ses 140 ans
donc l'esprit c'est de poursuivre
fidèlement son histoire ce qui est un
peu compliqué si on y pense j'aurais eu
un lieu qui fonctionne bien depuis 140
ans peut devenir un fardeau avec mon
expérience j'essaie de faire une très
bonne cuisine qui passerait bien et qui
ne soit pas trop cher
c'est un classique tout Madrid
pratiquement le connaît quoi
la cuisine madrilène je dirais qu'elle
n'existe pas
c'est plutôt une cuisine éclectique il
faut savoir qu'à Madrid il y a des gens
qui viennent de toutes les régions
d'Espagne et même de l'étranger donc la
cuisine de base n'est pas très simple il
y a le fromage cuit les sandwichs au
calamars et les tripes à la madrilène
mais pas grand chose d'autre
il y a une particularité dans la cuisine
madrilène c'est que l'on partage tous
les plats cette esprit de partage il
reflète la cuisse d'espagnol dès qu'on
partirait clairement ici vous pourrez
retrouver le meilleur de tout notre
territoire et aussi beaucoup de
l'Amérique du Sud puisqu'il y a une
grande influence espagnole là-bas et de
eux ici vous pourrez retrouver des
influences péruviennes colombienne et
aussi portugaise ou brésilienne
française aussi bien sûr la cuisine
française tu sais bien qu'elle a dominé
le monde pendant des années et encore
aujourd'hui donc nous allons cuisiner
maintenant pour faire une recette
qu'allons-nous faire avec toi bon alors
aujourd'hui nous allons faire une
recette dans laquelle ce mélange
beaucoup d'ingrédients elle s'appelle
salmorero avec une vinaigrette de
crevettes et du rhum cubain c'est un
plat andalou classique avec une
vinaigrette qui nous vient du Pays
Basque et un rhum de La Havane
allez maintenant on passe en cuisine
se fait avec une bonne tomate comme
cette tomate rouge et le panne du pain
et de l'eau de l'huile d'olive extra
vierge de l'ail et du vinaigre de
reresse la première étape
[Musique]
ensuite on prend la mie de pain
si possible on prend du pain qui date de
la veille
on met ça dans un bol et on mélange avec
un petit peu d'eau
[Musique]
ensuite on prend une gousse d'ail
il faut enlever le germe car sinon
ça peut te faire mal à l'estomac voilà
voilà
le vinaigre
[Musique]
et maintenant notre tradition c'est de
l'écraser avec les mains
et maintenant il ne reste plus qu'à
terminer avec le robot à l'avance bon
maintenant nous allons préparer la
vinaigrette sur laquelle nous allons
verser le salmorero
nous avons cuisiné des langoustines que
nous avons épluché et coupé
nous allons les mélanger avec les
oignons blancs et les tomates que nous
avons aussi assaisonnées
un peu de vinaigre du vinaigre de
graisse
un peu de sel
un peu de rhum
[Musique]
on mélange tout et ça y est c'est prêt
maintenant
on va verser la base
[Musique]
le petit truc de se place c'est que l'on
n'a pas besoin de le bouger tu le manges
avec ta cuillère de bas en haut en
profitant de cette saveur fraîche du
salon tu auras dans la bouche les
oignons les langoustines les tomates ce
n'est pas seulement une recette de
saveurs mais aussi de texture la texture
est fondamentale cela va te donner de la
joie et c'est ce que nous avons besoin
en ce moment
et maintenant on peut passer à la
dégustation
[Musique]
zone Europe c'est terminé vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en podcast
audio ou vidéo sur notre site Internet
et sur notre application radio sensation
et aussi sur TV 78 bon week-end et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]